yeah hello and welcome to this video I
should really win a game here and
playing terribly on the videos really
terribly it shouldn't really go below
2400 actually think below 2 5 is already
Terry so really should score points but
of course you only score if you play
somewhat decently and I really played
terribly I can make up the Scotch for
Knights main line now see success the
most common move not the only move of
course but that's what they normally
play but should be 6 yeah you can do
that of course it cannot be terribly bad
I'm just spilling my beverages my
beverage here all over the desk
not good
you know one of the positive points
about the Scotch for light is that this
particular setup you can basically play
with white whatever they do and this is
a nice feature especially if you are in
a blitz game rapid game whatever
anything that is a quicker time control
you don't really have to think all that
all that much and you can rely on your
on your general knowledge of the setup
yeah here c4 looks kind of ok I can also
take on e6 that's something you can
think about but this is this is fine I
mean I'm breaking the fourth rank
activity of the rook
hmm yeah even Knight h5 comes into
consideration at this particular moment
but unlike a dysphonia sits putting the
rook opposite the Queen
yeah not clear what blacks supposed to
do I'm not really threatening to take on
the 5k move the Queen it was one of them
likely moves now the capture I think is
a bit more attractive let's take it was
already a pretty good option move
earlier but now it's better as there is
no ePHI for example his pawns are just
weak so now you can even play Quincy
five-year in this particular situation
attack this taking on d5 it's also not
bad but probably attack too early
yeah like this it makes it looks
annoying somehow
I'm not sure if he goes a four in this
situation it does not but no I can take
an endgame is definitely nice for me
after taking oopsie five I'm just better
and quite a bit better actually
okay you're the easiest probably this
move okay so he gives me the pawn I'm
happy to take it I mean it's an outside
person I'm not going to give you
anything back buddy
I just don't do that and that ultimately
I don't think will help oh that's
interesting that he allows me to take it
only for I mean
[Music]
yeah I mean okay
yeah but ultimately I check him and go a
seven what is he doing here
how is he going to save himself
I don't see it I basically threatened
Bishop b5 - c6 and Knight to d6 I go
look at his seven maybe he's got night
c8 it looks terrible
but it could be could be working yeah
that could be actually working hmm not
good
I can I can just take that pawn but then
there's not b5
I just have hooked c6 and Ruka a success
how stupid I should have seen that a lot
quicker oh I keep missing very simple
resources really very simple resources
I mean not that this is bad or anything
it's just thinking I was just thinking
that this would work out entirely
differently
okay so
how to how to do that
let's try to get one of the points there
on the kingside I don't want him to play
king of three for sure we have six
seconds it's not and that's not a lot I
keep both pawns covered so he cannot
attack him my pawns with the King and
now I'm running up yeah the step looks
fine really not much that you can do
about this okay yeah that talks okay
and I can just run the king over to to
the to the other side
I'm just promoting now
and just keep everything it's just an
easy winner yeah yeah really really did
some weird technical decisions they're
probably okay but I'm glad too that I
have won a game first and foremost so we
had fairly standard position like here I
think you have to see who I should be
nicely positioned a 500 very normal and
now the engine okay
rookie one but taking is not bad the
reason why why does it better here is
that there was all those pawns here they
are somewhat weaker and mine are not I
mean I don't have a weak pawn and also I
have the better minor piece the bishop
will always be better than the noid so
this is also what the engine wanted to
do queen c5 maybe not the best yeah I
believe that
a four yeah after a forum you know what
I wanted to do and I think it does not
work fully I wanted to do this a former
take take take take
there should be five and now I see yeah
well okay five I've got a four okay and
this is actually still very nice
the appoint is going to be super strong
with 97 somehow saving that looks really
wacky that this should save you know it
looks like but this is nothing extremely
promising it seems the engines has equal
amazing okay in the game Queen to b6 and
now Queen d6 was good but this is also
just nice for white just a nice position
and a foreigner was giving me the pawn
not much I'm okay with that
with that phase of the game but somehow
here I don't know if I did this right
look c6 I just overlooked Nazi form
which is kind of embarrassing
of course I can do stuff like f3 as the
engine suggests or h4 I just did not
realize that this is going to happen
okay here I was a bit so I thought you
would take a 7 but anyway yeah and here
the way it turned out I think it looks
extremely promising with this yeah the
look is covering the two weaknesses and
I get to go to be one no could be lost
simply yeah I think it's lost don't
believe like and save that yeah
slightly shaky game technically but at
least I was basically calling the shots
now more time yeah thanks a lot for
watching